If you take this Claude skill, you
upload it to Claude, you'll get the
world's best SEO at your fingertips. It
will be able to do a full complete audit
of your SEO, give you actionable
insights, and walk you through your
entire SEO process for yourself or your
client with just one click. The first
thing that we want to do is add this
file onto our library. I'm going to
leave a link for the Claude skill below.
Just comment skill and I'll send it over
to you. So, once we add this skill over
to our library, as you can see I've
already added it, you can then go ahead
and follow the instructions. So, you can
go ahead and read through this. As you
can see, it's a very very in-depth SEO
audit workflow process.
When you use this skill, you want to
start by giving basic information like
business name, website URL, so on and so
forth. We're going to head back over to
the core work mode, and then we need to
enact the skills. So, we just enact
skills and use the ultimate SEO skills.
So, I found information about an actual
business that we're working with, and I
filled out the information so that the
AI can now give me the best possible SEO
plan.
So, once we fill out the information
about our business, our competitors, so
on and so forth, and we use the ultimate
SEO skill, that is all we need to do.
Give the information over to Claude, and
Claude will give you a full plan
starting from your GMB all the way over
to your on-page and off-page
optimization. We can see the workflow of
the process that Claude is using. It's
going to first research the website.
It's going to check our competitors.
It's going to do a technical SEO audit,
check Google Trends, generate a
comprehensive report, so on and so
forth.
So again, just going through the
workflow from Claude, we can see here
that it's doing a lot of things in
parallel. It's crawling the site.
Um we can see here that it's uh fetching
competitor sites as well. It's fetching
Google Trends information.
It's doing research on the Google
Business Profile review from 2025
and beyond. Okay, so we got the full
audit report. We can go ahead and take a
look at the report here.
So, we see the SEO audit. We see the
overall SEO score. We see the executive
summary of the actual website, the
opportunities, critical issues that you
need to fix this week, how to actually
go about doing so, and what tools to
use.
You also get a competitor analysis. You
can see what's working for your
competitors, what's not working, top
pages. You get the technical SEO audit
as well. Google My Business Profile
recommendations. So, you can see here
how to optimize your Google My Business
listing as well for more local leads,
keyword strategy, your so your priority
uh targets, your seasonal search index
based upon that specific website,
priority keyword targets, content
strategy, so 12 posts blog calendar,
schema markup, so you can literally go
ahead and copy over this schema markup
over to your homepage or to your custom
code so that Google will have more
information about your business, FAQ
markup, service markup. Really really
good stuff there. Very very useful.
Review strategies of how to get more
reviews, GMB post templates, so posts
which you can do on your template, and
then 90-day SEO roadmap with prioritized
action plan. So, essentially you get
every single thing you would need to
start
and to improve your SEO for yourself or
for your client with just using this one
skill. So again, if you want to get
access to the skill, comment skill below
and I'll send it over to you. As you can
see, it is a pretty in-depth skill. We
did not hold back on the information
that we gave it. We wanted to have a
one-and-done prompt that will get you
every single actual insight that you
need to improve your SEO. So, hope that
you guys enjoyed today's video. If you
did, let me know by giving us a big
thumbs up, and I'll see you in the next
one. Take care.